Hey hi Oh boob Oh bang II gone a haul
you left your face on the other side of
the room oh yeah and the layout in this
house is terrible
whoever designed it it's falling apart
the rooms go nowhere [ __ ] oh god oh oh
that's not my present yay
gimme don't even try to get up don't
even try it
don't I'm talking to you the last zombie
that got up after I whacked his face
will get whacked more in the fence okay
oh you son of a [ __ ]
you betrayed me I trusted you oh hello
Oh both of you want some ax you smell
smell you but should put on some axe let
me ask you a question what rhymes with
axe more ax all right I'm out of ax puns
Oh completely dark hey get up well who
did that who just bitch-slapped me don't
look at me like that
judgmental stares hi stop [ __ ] slapping
me
No oh now I'm in the trash compactor Oh
No
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh god damn
it all right okay
something's gonna happen oh oh no not
this again oh oh no I'm not ready I'm
not ready go go go go go go somewhere ah
[ __ ] me [ __ ] what oh good screw you
oh oh oh not you again oh go away go
away what are those things why are they
here huh why are they all staring at me
ah [ __ ] you good gimme get me out of
here well I don't like you I don't like
you I don't like you I don't like you Oh
Brandt
great I can't swing my axe ha ha ha okay
I can okay Oh oh man Oh screw those
things Oh screw those things they're
just mannequins but man oh god good get
away get away get away get away get away
get away
give me Eddie Oh screw you guy can you
get me out of here get me out of here
get me out get me get me get me on good
get me yeah ah no good Oh
oh go away oh go away
Oh oh that's creepy oh boy what am i
doing okay okay oh no no no I know I'm
all alone